he's got a 140 era against him he's
pitched very well against them he's seen
them very often and i'll tell you what
four pitch mix the fastball the
curveball the slider and the change the
changeup's been working the best he
really needs to get the slider and the
curve ball going but in the air to right
lucky bets
julio reyes will pitch around the lead
off walk and a lack of commander here in
the first jenny to not allow a ride
dodgers come to bat when you come back
it's good to have mookie bets back in
the lineup coming inside with an o2 bats
rips it down the left field line hooking
towards the corner and off the base of
the wall
that is a double for mookie bets and the
dodgers in business here in the first
this is impressive to come off of a hand
injury and to have them come inside and
him be able to trust it he's got some
really quick hips dodgers unable to
bring peterson in from third with her
first two chances
so it's up to corey seeger with two on
and two out here in a scoreless first
inning and he pops it to left that is a
bad missed opportunity for the dodgers
in this first inning second and third
nobody out and they fail to bring
lined
base hit to left field
telling you
secret weapon
trump's done a lot of damage with two
strikes too
first hit for the
giants now he has swings and he drives
one into deep left center field that is
hit real hard and one hops the wall at
the 375 marker over to play the carrum
is the left fielder peterson yaz into
second with a double
so the giants have a runner in scoring
position it's their second hit and it
will bring up donovan solano who has
been the big rbi man for the giants this
is hit out into left center field and
it's gonna fall
and bellinger's throw is gonna come home
the relay not in time
ski on the little pop fly that fell in
front of bellinger in shallow left
center comes around to score he's got
excellent speed and he needed all of it
right there one to nothing giants that
says the long dodger hit tonight doubled
in the first inning flips about a left
center field back goes rough on the
track it is gone
four consecutive at-bats with an extra
base hit for bets here a solo home run
to tie it at one
he just makes you smile this is some
kind of player
on a two on pitch bellinger pokes one to
left that's a base hit
and it gets by darren ruff
so bellinger will move into scoring
position
turner fly to center his first time
on the first one from samarja he pulls
the line drive base hit to left to put
the dodgers in front
oh the top of the order getting it done
here with two gone homer from bats
single with an error from bellinger and
then a rbi single from justin turner
makes it 2-1
that's flied to left his first time
muncie hits a ball well to deep right
field back towards the wall it is gone
lead off home run for muncie is fourth
and the dodgers lead 3-1
the 2-2 taylor
swings and lines one into center field
for a base hit
chris taylor
a single to center
so margin of smith on one and two
there's a fly ball to left field well
hit back to the wall is rough he leaps
he can't get it it's gonna homerun a
two-run home run for will smith his
second of the year
dodgers with three
here in the fourth lead at 5-1 and now a
2-2 that's it sharply on the ground to
third longoria with a nice play to get
the out at second but then the ball pops
out
and taylor's safe at first so bellinger
in the score at 6-1
for two he is lying down and struck out
and a fastball and flores drills it to
deep left and gone
he's on one fastball
and he's
looking at the ball sail out of the yard
well how about that
it's a little curveball curveball curve
on all sudden you try to sneak a
fastball by him and whoop there she goes
oh yeah sorry
he has had some good at bats he swings
here and lines one into right field base
hit that's a good at bat
aaron ruff is aboard with a lead off
single giant's down four two on nobody
out
he cracks one that's caught by muncie a
race to the bag
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't want these giants to start
chipping away and all of a sudden if the
offense shuts down this game gets
tighter max muncie makes sure
of this one
and almost gets two out of it
edwin rios
hitless in three at bats tonight goes
after the first pitch and hammers the
ball to right field way back there
gone
does it again his third in limited
playing time and the dodgers grow the
lead to five
first one that he's hit at dodgers
stadium
now will smith yanks a base hit over
short
[Applause]
home to crawford who swings at the first
pitch and a roller hernandez that's
another clean inning for jake mcgee
that's another win for the dodgers as
they beat the giants here in the series
opener by a final of 7-2
earlier you kidded about break up the
marlins at 7-1 but watch out for these
dodgers that's what the league's going
to be saying if they stay this hot